nous allons nous assurer que la personne
choisie soit la bonne personne non
seulement pour évaluer le travail qui
est en train de faire et qui doit encore
être fait mais aussi pour donner
confiance au Canadiens que ça va être
fait de façon indépendante irigoureuse
juste un truc sa vision de ce rapporteur
spécial qui l'envisage comme solution à
la crise sur l'ingérence étrangère qui
secoue son gouvernement depuis plusieurs
jours déjà un scénario qui n'a rien fait
pour calmer les ardeurs de l'opposition
la semaine dernière qui réclame à
l’unissant la tenue d'une enquête
publique le gouvernement sera-t-il forcé
de bouger voyons voir ce qu'on pense mes
collaborateurs à les castor gay est
animateur de midi info a ici première et
chroniqueur au Toronto Star et magazine
L'actualité et Michel serroger et un
chroniqueur politique à la presse c'est
Radio-Canada bonjour à vous trois
bonjour
le reportage le rapporteur spécial
c'était la bonne façon de faire pour
Monsieur Trudeau pour éviter l'enquête
publique
ça aurait été probablement la bonne
façon de faire
à deux égards c'est à dire si on l'avait
annoncé il y a 10 jours et pas en mode
rattrapage lundi ou si encore on l'avait
annoncé lundi il y avait un nom pour
aller avec le poste
mais d'une part c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de détruire un nom que de
détruire un concept flou dont on sait
pas trop s'il a été mis de l'avant pour
acheter du temps
deuxièmement en annonçant pas de nom et
en laissant passer quatre ou cinq jours
d'abord ça laisse penser que peut-être
que c'est pas si facile que ça de
trouver quelqu'un qui veut faire ce
travail là mais ça ça porte à quoi aussi
que beaucoup de gens qui pourraient
probablement être approchés regarde tout
ça il se disent pas nécessairement
intéressé moi les sacrifier une partie
de ma crédibilité professionnelle et
personnelle sur ce qui ressemble à une
cause un peu désespéré
Michel
chantal a dit gagner du temps c'est le
leitmotiv de la semaine la nomination du
rapporteur d'auteur qu'on avait pas de
nom c'est une façon de gagner du temps
quand on dit pas ça sera qui on gagne
encore quelques jours et toutes les
réponses de Monsieur Trudeau cette
semaine était à côté de la question
qu'on lui posait tout ce que le
gouvernement a fait viser à gagner du
temps le problème avec ça évidemment
c'est quand on a déjà est difficile de
crédibilité sur cette question là bien
sondages qui l'ont montré quand on ne
répond pas aux questions quand on a
l'air de gagner du temps comme vendredi
monsieur le ministre qui dit ah ben là
on va faire une consultation pour savoir
si on devrait avoir un registre un
registrement dans plusieurs pays en
Australie à nos États-Unis et il suffit
de vouloir le faire
là on va faire une consultation donc ça
va prendre une coupe de bois alors quand
tous ces toutes ces choses là pour
gagner du temps sur fond la crédibilité
du gouvernement qui a qui apprend pour
soi fallait qu'on a l'impression
effectivement les mots aussi j'ai
sourcié au consultations de Monsieur
Mendicino vendredi matin est-ce que le
gouvernement l'impression qu'il faut
acheter du temps parce que ça va
s'estomper ça va se calmer comme comment
vous comprenez ça cette façon de faire
oui probablement quand on se dit que la
relâche s'en vient Ottawa les députés ne
seront plus au Parlement la pression va
baisser un peu ensuite on a la visite de
Joe Biden le président américain le
budget fédéral afin du mois de mars ça
recommence seulement ensuite mis avril
on se dit bon l'opposition va devoir se
calmer un peu on a un mois devant nous
c'est une façon qui fait abstraction de
ce qui ne contrôle pas le gouvernement
ça c'est la partie qui le contrôle
évidemment que il y a une partie qui ne
contrôle pas c'est les révélations des
médias du globules de Global d'autres
médias il y a clairement à l'intérieur
des agences de sécurité des gens qui
estiment que le gouvernement ne prend
pas cette situation là suffisamment au
sérieux depuis trop longtemps eux
vont-ils jouer leur loge de la même
manière que le gouvernement vous
souhaite qu'on le joue il y a beaucoup
de questions là-dedans qui ont le
gouvernement n'a pas vraiment de réponse
alors est-ce que c'est intelligent ou
non
je pense qu'on aurait dû prendre les
devants de nommer le nom du rapporteur
général plus rapidement Chantal disait
écouté on est rendu 4 5 6 7 jours plus
tard on n'a pas de nom c'est
particulièrement bizarre
non pas sur l'idée du rapporteur spécial
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué une
enquête publique question de sécurité
nationale ça prendrait les paramètres
particuliers est-ce qu'on peut faire
autrement l'idée d'avoir quelqu'un qui
se penche là dessus pas mauvaise mais le
fait de ne pas avoir de nom ça sentait
l'improvisation la précipitation on
s'est dit bon ben le contrôle pas signé
il reste assigner quelque chose on va le
savoir demain ou après-demain
ça regarde pas bien pour le gouvernement
deux choses cela dit on peut présumer
que le sas la GRC qui sont mandatés pour
ça comité de parlementaire sur la
sécurité nationale sont capables de
faire leur travail aussi bien que nous
soi-disant enquête publique la vraie
question celle à laquelle serait simple
finalement de répondre c'est une
question de reddition de compte
politique la part du Premier ministre de
lui-même qu'est-ce qu'il savait quand
est-ce qu'il savait et qu'est-ce qui a
fait ça pas besoin d'être un secret
d'état et ça ça peut se faire dans un
endroit qui s'appelle un comité
parlementaire aussi on aime pas ça
mon collègue Peter mansrus a l'air semi
retraite disait
sixième position il peut donner une
longue entrevue et s'expliquer et
répondre aux questions mais j'ai
l'impression moi et là je vous dis ça au
pire que le gouvernement décidé de faire
cette bataille là justement sur le
terrain dont on parle à l'ex c'est à
dire que depuis deux jours trois jours
on commence à avoir des fuites dans les
médias qui dans un autre sens l'histoire
du visa diplomatique qu'on avait refusé
à un diplôme chinois l'ouverture
soudaine avait déjà vu la GRC aussi
prête à donner des entrevues sur des
enquêtes en cours moi j'ai rarement vu
ça dans ma vie de journalistes un
journaliste d'enquête mais c'est quand
même particulier souvent nager veut même
pas confirmer qu'elle fait une enquête
et là depuis trois jours j'ai assez
multiplié les entrevues et les appels à
tous pour parler de ces enquêtes et la
plus récente fuite entre guillemets qui
disent vous savez il y a trois sources
c'est global qui sort ça qui confirment
que l'intermédiaire qui aurait transmis
de l'argent du régime chinois pour faire
de l'ingérence sélectorale en 2019 et
qui est un élu antarien mais c'est un
progressiste conservateur alors écoutez
je suis pas considérationniste mais il
me semble que la main invisible derrière
ces sources c'est c'est fait là me
semble plus libéral que conservatrice
bon sans être conspirationniste Michel
justement parlons-en des conservateur
vateurs est-ce que c'est une bonne
semaine pour Monsieur Poirier est-ce que
est-ce qu'il en a retiré quelque chose
de positif
ce que Chantal mentionné est exact je
doute pas que ce soit monsieur poignet
on se retrouve à la fin de la semaine
avec
de gros problèmes parce que c'est beau
attaquer le gouvernement on l'a même vu
pour une rare fois être très sérieux et
être très efficace il y a des questions
et tout ça ça donne rien si à la fin
d'intermédiaire est un conservatoire
coûte rien alors ce même si c'est dans
le parti provincial et que techniquement
c'est pas il n'a pas de de relation
d'autorité sur ces gens-là mais
monsieur poignet se retrouve dans cette
situation d'avoir crié au loup alors que
pas regardé ce qui se passait dans sa
maison alors
il y a démontré qu'il était capable dans
une période des questions d'être
efficace ça c'est déjà un bon point pour
lui mais ça me met pas des points au
tableau ça un mot j'ai commencé avec
vous Alex sur l'impact que ça sur la
l'exercice démocratique la confiance des
Canadiens est-ce qu'on
a entendu des inquiétudes par rapport à
ça cette semaine est-ce qu'elles sont
justifiées d'après vous
je regardais le plus récent sondage
vendredi à Bacchus data qui posait des
questions assez précises sur cette
controversée autour de l'ingérence
chinoise ce qu'on constate c'est que
mise à part la base très très dure du
Parti conservateur qui déteste Justin
Trudeau à la base et qui elle croit que
les élections de 2019 ou 2020 ont été
entachés que les irrégularités ont
peut-être été suffisantes pour en
changer de résultat le Canadien moyen de
celui qui n'est pas la base partisane de
Pierre pollièvre n'en n'est pas là
actuellement mais il y a une inquiétude
on le voit la majorité des Canadiens
voudraient l'enquête publique il y a
quand même un bon tiers des Canadiens
qui suit d'assez près cette histoire là
ça peut paraître peu mais c'est beaucoup
pour une controverse un tiers des
Canadiens qui suivent une histoire
d'assez près alors il y a une inquiétude
il y a un potentiel de danger là pour
rejeter Trudeau il le sentit l'indique
il annoncé toutes ces mesures même si la
moitié avait de l'air mi-cuite là il se
parce qu'il se voit bien là qu'il
inquiétude on n'est pas rendu au moment
où les gens doutent de leur processus
électoral de la santé démocratique du
pays on en est pas encore là mis à part
chez une base très précise du Parti
conservateur mais c'est sûr que si ça
s'étire dans le temps là le danger va
prendre de l'ampleur
au sujet de la fraction dont Alex parle
il y a complètement raison ce sont des
peuures mais ce sont également des
chiffres qui correspondent à peu près au
nombre de conservateurs Canadiens qui
croient que l'élection américaine a été
volée puis Donald Trump et c'est la
moitié de la proportion de conservateurs
canadien qui croit que la lutte au
changement climatique est pas une
priorité alors il faut les remettre
aussi dans leur dans leur case qui est
une case relativement marginale dans la
vraie vie Michel rapidement
mais à la fin oui ça va jouer sur la
crédibilité du système électoral parce
que l'ingérence étrangère de la chute
d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose qui est
pas tolérable et le fait que le
gouvernement a pas eu l'air de prendre
ça au sérieux avant
pris beaucoup son temps va le
reconnaître le sérieux de ça joue aussi
là pas juste contre pour sur la
crédibilité du système électorale chaque
crédibilité du gouvernement
effectivement à suivre comme on dit
maintenant au Québec cette semaine on a
eu droit à des scènes qui ressemblaient
à ce qu'on avait vu le printemps dernier
devant les bureaux de passeport fédéraux
la ministre le risque première ministre
Geneviève Guilbaud est revenu en
catastrophe pour reprendre le contrôle
la chose on va l'entendre puis ensuite
Michel je commence avec vous moi
considère très imputable vous voyez ça
peut normalement c'est la direction de
la SAQ qui serait devant vous puis qui
s'expliquerait mais c'est moi depuis une
semaine et je vais continuer de le faire
taille aussi longtemps que ça va être
nécessaire parce que je veux que cette
situation là se redresse ce que je dis
c'est pas qu'il y a personne d'imputable
et tout ça puis entendez lui on fera les
analyses puis on verra qui a fait quoi
et qui devrait peut-être pas faire quoi
la prochaine fois
[Musique]
c'est elle qui est au micro c'est quand
même le ministre cair donc qui s'occupe
de ça normalement qu'est-ce que vous
comprenez de l'implication dans un gilbo
là
deux choses d'abord
elle est peut-être venue parce que c'est
pas montré c'était peut-être partie du
dossier d'autre part je ne peux pas y
voir autrement que le début de la
campagne à la direction de la carte de
Madame Guilbaud encore monsieur Legault
déciderait pour faire un troisième
mandat qui est bien possible
déjà elle arrive elle a dit moi je
prends le contrôle de ça c'est pas c'est
pas moi qui a fait l'erreur mais je
prends le contrôle
la deuxième c'est que Monsieur care lui
est allé se cacher littéralement son
mandat de son ministère parce qu'on est
un maintenant c'est d'aider les
ministères et les sociétés d'État les
sac moi j'ai rien à faire avec ça non il
avait affaire avec ça
monsieur cadre quand même pas une énorme
ministère de grosse responsabilités il
fallait qu'il soit là lui il a eu un
gros gros problème cette semaine et je
suis certain que son patron a pris
énormément de notes sur votre temps
il y a plein de monde qui ont pris les
notes cette semaine dans leur gardant
presque quand tu tentais d'expliquer ces
choses Alex là dessus qu'est-ce que vous
comprenez ce qui s'est passé cette
semaine
d'abord François Legault a été invisible
cette semaine il était en congé et il
doit une fier chandelle à Geneviève
Guilbaud pour ne pas avoir eu besoin de
sortir de sa semaine de congés parce que
elle elle est revenue en urgence
d'Europe pour gérer cette crise là la
SAQ ça tombe sur la responsabilité de
son ministère même si les affaires
informatiques c'est
Erica donc elle a pris ses
responsabilités elle a été très efficace
les problèmes sont réglés on a
l'impression qu'il y a au moins
quelqu'un qui s'en préoccupe ce qui
était pas le cas jusqu'à tant qu'elle
revienne d'Europe on peut pas dire
qu'effectivement
ericare lui a marqué beaucoup de points
auprès du bureau du premier ministre
mettons que de dire vous savez c'est pas
ma responsabilité je m'en occupais pas
puis après moi le déluge c'était
peut-être pas la sortie de la nuit
calibrée qu'on est entendue mais tant
que ça prenait un peu plus d'humilité ce
dont Geneviève Guilbault était capable
de faire preuve et quand même je vous
avais entendu l'extrait je viens
Guilbaud a dit ça devrait être la sac
qui est devant vous mais c'est moi mais
c'est parce que la SAQ est pas capable
non seulement de faire le travail
informatique mais elle n'est pas capable
de faire le travail de communication non
plus ça a été un désastre la première
sortie de Denis marcelet le PDG de
l'attaque grosso modo ben c'est de la
faute aux gens ils sont revenus en plus
grand nombre en succursale il y avait
juste à faire ça en ligne vous savez ça
sera pas frais ça sera
pas avec ça c'est dans deux mois mettons
qu'en terme de communication c'était pas
particulièrement gagnant on a entendu ça
les numéros allumés au bureau de janvier
gilbaud puis on a dit bon on va être
obligé de s'en occuper lui aussi a perdu
pas mal de points pour cette semaine
auprès des auprès de ces patrons donc
tandis que c'est réglé au moins il y a
de l'air d'avoir un capitaine quelque
part c'est déjà la moindre des choses
parce que dans la première semaine il y
a on n'avait pas l'impression que
personne s'en préoccupait
cette explication c'est la faute des
gens quand on disait ça va mal dans les
aéroports parce que les voyageurs ont
oublié
c'est ça
être un bon politicien c'est aussi dans
ce cas-ci rendre un bon service à son
gouvernement et consigner les deux d'une
part d'autres parts c'est faire preuve
de bons réflexes puis on passe à 7 ans
critiquer les politiciens qui ont pas de
réflexes on pourrait en nommer un
aujourd'hui on a nommé je pense que
effectivement François Legault lui en
doit une mais il y a un mal pour un bien
pour le gouvernement dans l'expérience
de cette semaine avant de s'embarquer en
santé dans le genre d'opération qu'on
vient de voir il va falloir y penser
deux fois plus tôt qu'une parce que on
peut pas se permettre un cafouillis de
cet ampleur là sur ce front là
excellente façon de conclure
effectivement parce que transition
numérique en santé ça sent bien on n'est
pas là encore mais il y a plusieurs
qu'on prend des notes là-bas Alex
Chantal Michel merci infiniment à la
semaine prochaine au revoir